my name is dawn viens I'm a professor in
plant breeding of genetics in the school
of integrated plant sciences here at
Cornell and we put together a program
for our first Hempfield day ever
where fortunately we have some
nice-looking hemp for you to be able to
see and I noticed everybody was kind of
roaming around looking at it and you'll
have opportunity to do that a little bit
later on as well but we have a lineup of
some of us here from Cornell who are
working with hemp and we have quite a
few people and the number of people are
growing who are interested in working on
different aspects of hemp in terms of
research and extension and and we also
have Chris Logue who I'm not sure he is
here yet but oh there he is wonderful
he's from the department of agricultural
markets who is going to be talking a
little bit later on about the potential
years as the marketing of hemp and also
some of the regulatory issues that that
growers need to keep in mind
I noticed that looking at the list of
all of you who have signed up or
enrolled online for this field day that
there's a wide variety of backgrounds
that you come from and interest that you
have about hemp so what I would like to
do is to keep this informal certainly
there are half a dozen or so of us who
are going to be giving talks but to keep
it informal such that as you have
questions or even comments or want to
get into a discussion about anything
just barge in at any time to do that
okay so so it would be more fun that
this was more of a two-way discussion or
a multiple way discussion then if it's
just us up here lecturing to you so keep
that in mind we also have Assemblywoman
Donna Lupardo who is somewhere close by
but I don't think she's here there she
is
Oh wonderful so she's just waving her
hand there I wanted to recognize her
because she is the one who initiated all
of the discussions about industrial hemp
and the potential uses here in New York
State and and as the subsequent
legislation and essentially paved the
way for us to be able to I mean without
her we wouldn't be having this
right now essentially so let's give her
a round of applause for what you've done
[Applause]
and certainly any time that you want to
contribute to the discussion feel free
to jump right on in so so again we'll
keep this very informal so what I'd like
to do is to start out by just telling
you how we got into this research here
at Cornell University in the first place
and and I started last year with the
Department of Agriculture and markets
who made some funding available to us to
to start out by evaluating varieties of
industrial hemp that come from Canada
and Europe by and large and to see which
ones will perform the best under our
conditions in New York State until we
have time to actually do some breeding
specifically for new or state conditions
so that's what this set of trials is all
about here there are a couple of people
who will explain more about this in a
little while from now so I won't try to
steal their thunder but but by the time
we went through all the the regulatory
approval process that had to be done in
tandem we couldn't do it all at the same
time it wasn't until late August of last
year that we were able to actually
purchase some seed and obviously that's
too late to get some good experiments
going but but my research crew planted
out some small trials only about a mile
in that direction from here at the first
of September last year not to really get
good data on harvest I mean by the time
that froze sometime in November was only
about six or eight inches tall but at
least it gave us a chance to to see how
well we could establish some experiments
they actually try it out to different
planners and got some good data so we
have a little experience behind us
before doing the wheeled trials this
summer and you can see behind me that it
was very successful in establishing good
trial there so that's what last year was
all about but what I'd like to do is to
turn this over to dr. Chris smart to
describe more of what the research plans
are for us here at Cornell and not only
what we're doing now but what we plan to
do in the future and and what's
happening in terms of
of production around the state in
regards to research Chris is a professor
in the section of plant pathology and
plant microbiology in the school of
integrated plant science and she's the
one who is coordinating all that we're
doing here with industrial hamp in our
college and on top of that she's she's
also a director I know you're interim
director but essentially you're director
arias today is the day oh she is she is
the director of the school of
integrative plant science Chris well
thank you Donna and welcome everyone to
Cornell it is a beautiful day and this
is a really remarkable hemp trial Don
and his crew have done a great job in
terms of the research that we're doing
here we now at Cornell let me give you a
bit of a history last year in 2016 there
were 15 or 16 states across the u.s.
that had industrial hemp
research projects this year and Don's
group was one of them it was really
fantastic that he was this year there's
31 states so industrial hemp is booming
and we have a lot of folks to
collaborate with across the country so
it's really nice that the state has
enabled us to jump in and really get on
the wave of industrial hemp that's
happening right now in terms of what
we're doing
we now have 11 scientists at Cornell
that they and folks in their labs have
projects on industrial hemp last year
this time we had one so so the state has
definitely got us enthusiastic about
industrial hemp we also have ten
educators from Cornell Cooperative
Extension across the state that are
involved in bringing information to
growers about how to grow hemp and and
you know what can we do this year in
terms of hemp and how are we looking to
the future so that's really exciting in
terms of some of the research that we'll
be doing there is a research project
actually that is run through Cornell but
it's actually a state-funded project
where this year there are 29 farms that
are involved in the research project
these are farms
that are all growing the same variety of
industrial hemp that variety is Enka the
reason we chose ANCA was not some
amazing scientific literature driven
reason it's really the seed that we
could get a hold of at the time we
decided to do this large-scale project
but it is a dual purpose a variety of
hemp so it'll be interesting to see how
it does on these 29 different farms in
terms of the research we know what the
history of the land that anchor is being
grown on we know we have soil tests and
we'll have weather data will have yield
data so we'll know really how this
variety does we have farms from Lake
Erie all the way down to Long Island
growers are amazingly entrepreneurial we
have growers that are growing for fiber
and procede we also have growers that
are growing plants in the greenhouse and
transplanting them out to extract the
medicinal compounds the non
hallucinogenic non THC medicinal
compounds and they'll be selling those
and then we have growers that are
actually harvest being two to three week
old plants and using them for baby
greens in salads and whatnot
so I've been amazingly impressed again
continually by the growers in the state
of New York how entrepreneurial you
folks are and all the different uses and
and creative ways that you can find to
thrive in this farming environment it
has been a tough year we've had a lot of
water my background is in surgeon my
background is in plant pathology I study
diseases of vegetables and if you're a
vegetable girl you know it's been a
tough year it's been hard to get in
because of all the rain but our growers
have gotten the hemp in it's gotten in
late and we'll be enthusiastic to see
what we learn at the end of the season
in terms of other research projects
Larry and Larry smart who's a plant
breeder in the school of integrative
plant science as well he and Don vines
are going to be establishing a breeding
program one of the things that we
learned this year we Don scrutiny last
year is that because of the permitting
issues that Chris Loeb will talk about
you know moving seed across state or
country lines can be extremely difficult
and so be really great to establish a
seed production industry here in New
York so that New York growers can buy
seed produced in New York alleviating
some of the permitting issues and that
will be coming online but but just
starting a breeding program from scratch
takes time and so we're also working
with local seed companies to try to find
ways to import the seeds more smoothly
than what happened this year
additionally in that program we will be
establishing a THC and CBD CBD SR the
non hallucinogenic compounds medicinal
compounds produced by have a testing
facility that hopefully a year from now
both researchers and growers will be
able to use to determine what varieties
have higher levels of those medicinal
compounds and when grown here in New
York so those compounds do change
depending on the environment depending
on water content and depending on heat
so that's going to be an important
aspect of our program we have plant
pathologist that's going to be studying
plant diseases we have an entomologist
that's looking at insects we have a
system scientist who's looking at how
hemp fits into a rotational system we
have also I along with a microbiologist
are looking at the microbiome you've
heard that you know what's in your gut
and on your skin helps make you who you
are healthy and things like that well
we're actually going to be looking at
the microbiome of hemp to see what kind
of microbes grow on hemp and how that
might impact some of the products that
we get out of it so that's some of the
research that we're going to be doing at
Cornell and and we're really excited
actually just to be involved with the
growers and to learn from you guys you
know what your needs are but also what
you're learning on your farms and how we
can bring that back and feed those
questions and those solutions into our
research program I also want to say that
we do have another field day in Geneva
on
Tuesday August 15th so the Geneva plots
we have Cornell has campus in Geneva
spot and our North Pier we have four
trials here that Dawn's group will talk
about today we have two identical trials
to these four in Geneva and those trials
don't look quite like this so when we're
in Geneva will actually be talking about
some of the struggles that you might
have if you're pointing a hemp crop you
know this this is beautiful as I've
heard you know some of the researchers
are like wow if I knew it was going to
look like this you know I heard a
heartbeat but what happens when enough
you'll get to drown out what do things
look like what disease and insect
purchase do you have and things like
that so we'll have some of the extension
folks there and we'll talk about some of
the some of the issues that you could
have if you're if you're growing a hemp
crop and with that I think I would turn
it over to sit your folks back to Don
some of you who have stood up close to
them here may have noticed that these
grain varieties here that orange loom
there's a lot of bees in their bubble
caves and honey bees and so forth
they're really doing a lot of
pollinating in a couple of him sort of
fallen solution also was thinking as I
came out this morning and I was looking
on must write in this way but on the
other direction this stand of subjects
that you can easily use this for you
know like to have corn mazes and stuff
like that to pathways maybe maybe once
the regulations allow for that to happen
we could have had mazes we'll see what
happens in the future next up we're
going to have a couple of people from a
research program talk about the actual
trials that are going on here to
evaluate varieties for our conditions
here in New York State so I'd like to
introduce two people to come up Jaime
Crawford who I really have to to
acknowledge has done a lot of work to
make the logistics of all of these
things that we're doing with hemp happen
she's been very instrumental to pulling
off a lot of things there so Jaime is a
research support specialist on the
forage breeding project which is the
project that I lead but of course
we're into hemp research as well and
along with her is Amelia Goffe who is
actually completing an internship with
us she's actually from SUNY Cobleskill
and has to do an internship in order to
complete her degree requirements they're
a Cobleskill so she became interested in
industrial hemp and we took her on as a
intern to work with the hemp project the
summer and has done a lot of really nice
things there I'm going to turn it over
to the two of them good morning I have a
bunch of things to tell you and I knew I
forget so you have actually a handout so
what I'm going to talk about is called
2017 industrial hemp trials so the very
first table on that sheet shows you our
different locations for our trials and
the plan TV so the trial you see behind
me right here this is this one was
planted June 9th and you can see it done
very very well which ones are actually
behind me this is our grain and
dual-purpose variety trial and then we
also had four entries that are exclusive
fiber varieties and so those are the
next blocks down so those of you
interested in fiber should go and check
those out as well so you can see we
planted while Crispin mentioned how far
behind the trials were in Geneva they
were planted later so we planted a
second trial on this exact same soil
type the day after we planted the first
Geneva trial and that is what's down at
the far end so you could be able to see
a little bit of a difference a
difference three weeks can make the
varieties are still photo period
sensitive so you can see that even
though they are much shorter they're
still starting to flower at about the
same time within the last two weeks
luckily we've had two people from
different Canadian seed companies come
and visit us and they said that even
though it's planted later it will still
be harvested and like let's see so since
there's a three week difference in
planting they'll probably be a week in
half difference in harvesting time so
it's not going to be you know it's not
the full three-week difference for the
harvest so you can see our other trials
on on here so we have one other child
here in Ithaca that was planted on and
what I would call it's challenging soil
so it's what we plant we plan to the
trial on it last year and what we
planted with a grain drill so it was
planted about a one-inch seeding depth
it just didn't come up at all
it was terrible so we planted it this
year with a forage feeder aiming for
about a half inch feeding depth and then
bad luck right about two days after we
planted it we got a rain and then two
nights in the 40s and so the emergence
in that field is not what you see here a
little a sort of an understatement in
the trial right behind me we're
averaging between between 10 and 18
seedlings per square foot and on that
other trial I was just talking about we
were averaging between four and seven
seedlings per square foot so it was a
big difference a big difference and then
we have the two trials planted in Geneva
one of them on a moderately well-drained
soil and so on on a somewhat poorly
drained soil so we know we have those in
New York State and then our last trial
is on a gravel it's the only one that
had a lot of rock so our last trial was
planted in an organic system and on the
in free ville and so that was in that
was rotating out of red clover and then
we planted hemp into it so we're really
looking forward to what we see in that
one so if the plots behind me each one
is well this is sort of a joke so one of
the students pointed it out to me after
I was kinda data so our plots are four
feet by 20 feet so everyone can make a
422 so you have to have one at a hemp
meeting right
so each entry is replicated four times
throughout each trial like I said we
were aiming for our grain jail for about
three-quarters of an inch for a seating
depth and all of our child except for
the beasts typical one where we aim for
a half an inch and then if you want to
look at the back you can see a list of
the varieties that we have in the trial
so we've got 13 varieties that are
listed as grain or dual purpose so the
ones you see on the signs here the four
fiber try four or five are entries which
you can see down there and then there's
also some contact information for the
seed companies that we got these
varieties from so for future trials we
do we do hope to get more entries we
want to be able to show for the farmers
of New York State you know the full
spectrum of what's available to them so
there's a couple other seed companies in
Canada that ran out of seeds this year
so we're hoping to get some of their
entries from parklands for next year and
yes so next amelia is going to talk to
you a little bit about some of the notes
that we've taken yes marina why don't
you just tissue culture this cannabis
that grows organically here in this
indigenously in new york to start a
project I already have cold weather and
the soil hardiness Canada South I
that would not be commercially available
to farmers right now like the purpose of
these trials right now is to see what
farmers can purchase and plant in their
fields right now
so like yeah I'm here I'm trying to talk
to you about the variety trials that we
have that's part of a future breeding
program right so the whole idea we would
of course you know native hemp varieties
are of interest in breeding programs but
for the trials like this is what a
farmer can get feed of and plant next
spring so that's that's what we need to
show yes any other questions for our
task is this variety there that has this
extremely high
the expected growth the success rate
will never I don't think it will ever
get quite this tall favor I did today
was it starts that little period change
it stops it upward what is equality the
gentleman who came last week he he is
the one who markets unka so rubenstone
he was saying that they have areas where
they've planted unka and beginning of
May and that's like 15 feet tall
so yes sensitive about that one over
Canada as well
all access using makeup a joy I think
that's what Larry there's nothing
official yet but that would be the one
of the first cold reading program was
over something
prevent this auto so I'm a bring in
Amelia and she's going to talk about
some of the notes that we've taken on
the trials so far
hi so I'm the research intern and with
the help of some of our student
employees they've been collecting data
on our trials on a weekly basis most of
these data include notes on Heights and
and flowering as you can see all of our
varieties our flower and bloom now I
think the fiber may just be beginning
the fiber varieties have been much
slower to begin and something I've
noticed is there's vast differences
between our Manisha's and dioecious
varieties and for those of you who don't
know
dioecious varieties are the ones that
have male and female plants that are
separate and manisha plants produce male
and female parts on the same plant all
of our dioecious varieties began to
bloom sooner and they had they did so
much more vigorously at first and then
their growth sort of slowed down where
the money shows varieties have continued
to grow a lot more at a much more study
in linear rate we plan on combining that
our grain and dual purpose varieties in
the fall when about 70% of the seeds are
mature and so we're expecting to do that
probably September October and our fiber
trial will be harvested when 20%
flowering occurs so that's all we have
to know there is there is enough one
year without this
monies that are only used for breeding
they're not generally put in the field
just curious why
with weather are the operating writings
animations I think that's right already
they work just because metacognitive
manesis cultivars are generally only
grown by plant breeders is that they
respond to the dancers that produce less
either
I'm not sure that that's truly but a lot
of people prefer money sits ready
because they won't lose 40 percent of
their traps unisex male plants yeah
that's right receptor yeah will you be
using the seed from these in future
playthings what about cross-pollination
between any of them no now replant we
plant certified seed in our child and so
we won't be saving any seeds
well we will test the quality of these
these for different oil production but
when it comes to planting again we're
going back to the 35 bags and it's
illegal we would point out that it is
effective to say disease but what is the
Cris okay it is not an intellectual
property good look at it
there are sun-dried tomato on another
absolutely fundamental gate with but
it's also a little different I mean
women are not allowed to call me went
straight there are ago but if you have a
sinner to Eric that legal so whatever
someone has mean under your if you have
a life to do that I'll be square singles
and it is legal what is going on sorry
the question was can you clone the plant
with can you put them into tissue
culture and that's absolutely something
that we're going to be doing here at
Cornell in fact the director of our
tissue culture facility is here today
but you have to have the appropriate
licensing from the company who sold you
the seed and you also have to have the
appropriate permit so that Matthew
doesn't get her in jail we like it we
like
reading efforts focused on varieties or
strategy that won't necessarily incur as
many licensing issues of material
censored agreements for farmers and will
not well i means like eventually
ideality gold will be able say nice
piece of hemp and won't be reading some
drive that might previously have such
restrictions on them I think all are the
only things I have
yeah I'm not sure how to answer I didn't
quite hear the whole question there is
something about reading what well well I
guess some of these varieties I have
like the agreement then you can't repeat
leave a seed right is that legally so if
the companies and the guiity are the top
of federal regulation oh yeah so that's
absolutely right that happens with the
most crop species even without alphabet
you see the plots behind you there that
we work with on a project as well
especially the private companies will go
through what's called a plant variety
protection some will actually patent
their varieties and so that's a legal
process so that makes sure that that you
or I cannot pirate their seed and call
it our own variety they put all the
expense into the research and
development of that variety and
producing the seed and so forth they
want to protect it so that they can get
some payback so that it continued with
with their efforts there so that's just
part of the legal protection system it's
not part of the drug enforcement agency
or anything like that but it's just just
part of the system to to make sure that
companies are protecting their own
interest of with and I don't say that in
a selfish way that's that's kind of the
way it needs to be in order for
companies to have the incentive to put
all the funding into research and
development of products like this does
that answer your question
but when you then read off of varieties
that have those protections of dido
looking you forward so if we do that we
need to go to that company and ask if
they would allow us to do that and sign
an agreement and of course we'd have to
pay them a royalty on any varieties that
we developed from their materials
usually there's a royalty basis per
pound of seed you know so many cents per
pound of seed that we have to pay back
to them there's couple patent attorney
over here there's couple definitions
going on you may actually be able to
patent the gene sequence you can't
patent the whole genome but you might be
able to patent the sequence to give it a
particular characteristic in that case
any of us wouldn't be able to grow
I have plans with that particular gene
sequencing because then we would be
violating their patent but if you enter
into a license agreement with one of
these companies then there's potentially
additional restrictions on top of
whether or not you can actually breed
with their plan technically you know by
the patent law itself if you breed with
their plant and then produce something
without that patented gene sequence
you might technically be okay by the
patent laws but by the license agreement
you might not write right any other
questions about anything that they did
that yes the early plans to test auto
follows soil model flour yeah we haven't
thought about that at least I haven't
but that might be an interesting thing
to do I have insured it was like going
generousity how much does he cost Danny
what we have the paper that my team
we're going to be cost it it's probably
two dollars fifty cents to $3 a pound
project and then you pay for all of the
testings that they have to do through
apex to get it imported to the United
States and then the shipping is
expensive on top of that as well and
then I don't know what did we work it
out to Christy remember like it was
subdued roughly $50 an acre and
reproduce $2 and is easier for the
seesaw that was for lower forego yeah
that was also when we bought it involved
so we bought 50 1000 pounds of it and
got it at about 50 so we about $50 for
no sir proposed route 30 yeah so the
question was how many pound per acre and
we were planning at 30 pounds per acre
which was about the $50 Mitch yes I
think for the oil fall in the fire
content will you take a look at the
pharmaceutical value of this crop even
though I know it's not intended for that
person yes we're very interested in
doing that so what we would like to do
is that I mean SUNY Binghamton has a
pharmaceutical school now and we talked
to them about a year ago about interest
I know they're working with some other
people now too but but we would like to
get some people interested in looking
that right so the question was I think
if I heard it right I think the question
was are we going to be looking at other
non THD medicinal compounds yeah so this
year again we're getting that up and
running so we'll just do it as a
one-shot deal we have a quenelle our
Parc bio Resource Center will be gearing
up for that
so we'll test for THC and then for the
cannabinoid panel and then next year the
idea is that you know we'd have more
time to plan a more rigorous scientific
study and we would probably do different
timings but at least for this year we'll
get information from the 17 varieties
that leave the snapshot and we'll do
that for each of our six locations that
has a variety okay thanks for clarifying
that Chris because yeah we can't we're
not doing everything this year this is
our initial year put in the future we
would like to do that yes don't think
we're size before about harvesting
equipments want to sort of throw it out
if you had what are you guys doing for
combines or making adjustments
economizer because a specialty equipment
you guys are looking into for they would
have you know suppers so I think has a
general question for everybody and I
were talking about that before we
started here about harvest equipment
that you use and would probably be
different for the fiber varieties versus
the grain and dual purpose varieties I
mean I've heard I've read that that
people have used a combine for the grain
and dual purpose times
sometimes there can be some problems
with with all that stock material
wrapping around the components of the
combine so that is an issue anybody have
any experience with that or thoughts on
that using a handle working using water
hammer and the quarter caters or yeah I
know a farmer is or not that actually
left the remainder of the hem field
because it showed about two or three
days at the combine for any burrs no
really
and they had repeatedly stop and on wide
the combine in restart veins has linked
and whatnot because the fiber is just
too much for their John Deere combines
them so that could be an issue and I
know that's a common issue throw the
hemp industry right now is the hardest
thing of it yeah so that's that's
something where some agricultural
engineers could come in handy to work
out that system but there is I mean
obviously there's a lot of fiber in
there even in the grain types there's a
lot of fiber I mean otherwise this tall
material wouldn't stand up like it would
we're just catching up with the rest of
the world here are their sheaves another
country has because orichalcos always
challenge the hemisphere lawyer my
competences facility the some partners
from the University of Taiwan and
in China they've been doing some China
plus million years a second you can buy
these on machine and eventually they
buried all these hot oil and impulse buy
where's your company and previously
induces then with that but at least my
teachers okay thank you
other questions before we go on to the
next speaker okay I'm curious what
you'll be doing next year or any
research on like the system's work what
follows as well how to deal with all the
fibers in the music yeah I mean Chris
can help me answer that because she's
been see and she and Larry smart have
been thinking about this I mean one of
the things that we want to do too
right now we just have these these
variety trials just on Cornell and we
would like to spread that out on
throughout the state right now producers
several producers are just growing ANCA
but we would like to get some variety
trials more widespread so we can get a
better idea of the best varieties for
New York State conditions not just on
our experimental farmland
so that's one but Chris I don't know if
you want to contribute more yeah so here
we so yeah it in terms of on far more
rotational strategies there's a
scientist Matt Ryan who's in the soil
and crop science section up tips and
he's going to be looking at integrating
hemp into his system study and then in
addition to that I think you know one of
the things that we can do fairly fairly
easily is right now we're looking at
what is hemp following at the 29 farms
and there's some interesting case
because there were some girls that you
know sprayed and we're ready to prep
prep for soybeans but they couldn't get
their soybean in because of the rain and
now they're putting HAMP in so will
be able to tell you know do the
herbicides that were on the prep for
soybean are they attack you know
identity perhaps so in some ways the
twenty nine farms are helping us with
that the other thing that we'll be hope
with is that we can go back to them next
year and see if they're having issues
you know what are they following and are
they having issues so we can follow that
for a while so so right now we are
developing our systems approach but we
can use the twenty nine farms sort of as
a real life that you know scientific
study to see what happens so and any of
you you know if you once you guys start
growing hemp and you know anything that
you found has has affected to have
either that you did before the head goes
in the ground or after it's coming off
going in the next year I mean that's all
really valuable information that you
know we hope to learn from you guys any
other questions before we move on yes I
was curious to know if you waters it or
they just rely on over here yeah we've
had plenty of rain you did irrigate it
wants to start with it yeah we had one
dry spell in June and at that time we
weren't sure the DEA was going to allow
us to plant in all of our locations
they're like we need this to survive so
we did irrigate it for I know just a
couple hours one morning it's a very
early seedling stage but none of the
other trials were irrigated we just were
this like we just to survive what
happens if it cooks and so there was an
act of desperation here just to make
sure but and it turns out it probably
have been fine but but none of the other
child's have been irrigated obviously
it's been an unusual year last year was
so dry and this year or so wet and if
you put the two years together and ever
just help it but that's not the way to
plant act they don't work on averages so
you know with all the rain that we've
had this season
each week we wonder well this is a false
it going to turn off and then it's going
to turn dry the rest of the summer and
you just never know but it's just it
just keeps on going
so so with I mean we got this planted
late later
maybe several weeks maybe a month later
than what we really wanted to plant it
but yet it's growing very tall and so
you know we've had plenty of moisture to
keep it going
this season other questions yes do you
have any faculty positions opening at
the Cornell or anyone know the court
cannabis genetic I know a lot of you
people are kind of taking on this with a
new plan but what about people who
specialize in Hanson Canada for that or
Chris but I'm not aware of any new
backer positions right now all right we
do have new faculty positions but so the
ones that we have right now or not
they're not estimated well exacting
actually to answer that question quite
seriously I think that I think that
hiring a subsea member for a forty
thirty or forty years ten or twenty
thirty years that you know is a serious
and government and I think that we don't
know yet how well-kept is going to do in
New York I mean this is really the first
time that's been and so you know I think
we need to give it a season or two to
figure out how we plug that in to our
research portfolio and footprint across
the state you know to make sure that you
know we still have have folks that are
working with our vegetable growers and
our field crops growers you know just to
make sure we're very well rounded and so
I think the people that are on hand far
you know we're all in and I feel like
you know we're covering it quite well
and in the future if it continues to
expand and we would certainly look into
that area I mean we have the advantage
of Chris mentioned earlier that they're
11 of us on the faculty working on this
and we're all coming from our different
areas of specializations put together as
a package where we're cooperating
together to you know to look at the
complete package so it's not just
breeding or genetics but it's all
different areas of research that we're
working on here and that's really what
it's going to take that's what's going
to take the work because it's not just
one area specialization that we need to
be focusing on but we need to look at
all aspects of production and so forth
ok yes
Perry thought about building communities
in terms of worker cooperative to such
so that the extraction crisis and the
processing devices can be bought back to
the farm community that's all where all
the money is you know it's one thing to
grab the plaintiff in this action farm
and key process into you know five
hundred different new sensors the money
interesting wondering if it's all about
that yeah I'm not totally sure what your
question has something about their
system I mean equipment back to the farm
so in for instance in North Carolina to
being movement about building farm
worker cooperatives where they will buy
dates are normally go to the market that
money save on car payments in marijuana
on the west coast farmer delegate it's
all the processes and building harness
some curious as to whether well when
your state is thoughtful in thinking
about building those for marketability
yeah so we have a partner are you here
hey you are yeah we have Cheryl so
hardest New York corn up quark xtension
you know I don't have an answer to that
right now I am familiar with what's
going on in North Carolina I don't know
that any thoughts been given that that
yet I would say to it's just too new yet
so far um so I know Chris is work rep
he's going to talk about talking about
processors towards the end of it but I
don't have an answer right now is that
it's a great question though let me move
on we'll have more opportunities for
questions we're not done yet this
morning but let me move on before I
introduce the next speaker though I
might mention some of you may have
noticed or maybe didn't notice the poll
offense that's around our experimental
farm here so that fence is there because
we have a lot of deer problems around
here and you know you see some four
species behind alfalfa and so forth if
we didn't have some way to control the
deer we wouldn't be able to collect the
data for our research purposes that we
need to collect so so I don't know I
mean people have asked me of deer or a
problem on hampt and I don't really
don't know the answer to that we haven't
had experience with it yet have any of
you heard anything about whether deer
will bother hamp at all yes I think
Burma
such the peopling of veneer really liked
photos that have grew tall and more
fibrous that yours
oh okay too much fiber in there might
depend on what a cultivar really
so even have this fence here they would
be anywhere else alphabet leaving the
hem alone okay if you notice mainly on
dog on young growth my arm for CBDs and
didn't say at what point there okay yeah
I've grown for CVP in Oregon's we've had
no problem with you at all we have
multiples like four different farms gone
right now over an area so we've been
very fortunate and I'm okay everybody
here that so he said and work and they
haven't had any problems at all with
their okay let me introduce the next be
heard you know anytime you have more and
more acreage of any kind of a crop
species and right now we don't have that
a lot of acreage but it's growing but
whatever you have that it's going to be
susceptible to various disease and
insect problems so dr. Gary Bergstrom
he's the the chair of the department or
the section of plant pathology and plant
microbiology within the School of
Integrative plant science and he does a
lot of research and extension activities
on diseases of field crops and Ellison
shields our entomologist was going to be
here but he's some things came up and
he's not able to be here today but he
did tell me about a few insect problems
but if you've seen any insects so then
you're okay well let you talk about
disease okay thanks Don so I will
confess that I'm a student of a of hemp
diseases at this point and trying to
learn everything I can along I suspect
with a lot of you here so as Don said
I've worked in in field crops for a
number of years and we are looking
forward to getting a better handle an
inventory on what some of the pest
problems are on industrial hemp and I've
also spent some time talking to some
colleagues and some other parts of the
country and some of these recent
visitors from Canada about some of the
they've encountered but by-and-large
we're going to use these variety plots
and Ithaca Geneva and other places and
these distributed farms across New York
State to try to inventory all of the
pest issues that that we find and
typical for a new crop like this a lot
of these pathogens tend to be rather
specific in the and the crop species
that they attack so we could reasonably
expect as we expand the acreage and
intensity the crop we may not see a lot
of these pest problems now but we we can
anticipate that they would increase the
more that we grow the crop intensively
on a particular farm or or more
extensively so I think most of you aware
there are no pesticides of any class
used on the crop at this point and that
includes fungicides and that also
includes a seed treatment fungicides dr.
Alan Taylor is going to talk a little
bit later on the program about some seed
treatment technology one of the things
we would be concerned about is what
protection we need to get these seeds
seedlings out of the ground and we one
thing we have noticed in a number of the
locations at fairly low incidence not
really causing an economic problem but
we could see even in this fairly dry
season we have seen a number of the
water mold pathogens attacking the the
seed and seedlings that under less
favorable conditions for sowing the crop
we could anticipate more problem and in
the vast majority of field crops and
vegetables we except for strictly
organic production there's often a seed
applied fungicide or water mold active
material so that's something that we
will be looking at in the future as a
possible means of controlling some of
these problems
we've also seen a fairly small incidence
of some of some wilting and and
found in route symptoms at low incidence
and I could share a whole long list of
Latin names with you of the kind of
organisms that we're finding there but
at this point we're just taking an
inventory and some of this goes back to
what Chris was talking about the
microbiome there are a lot of fungi and
bacteria and other things that are just
normally present and just define some of
these things doesn't necessarily mean
that they're there causing some kind of
a plague on industrial hemp so part of
the research going forward will be
taking some of these organisms trying to
inoculate them onto healthy plants and
seeing if they do cause disease and down
the road I mean I'm very excited about
this breeding program that will be going
on we'll look at some of the principal
plant pathogens that we find associated
with the crop and maybe doing or someone
in the future will be doing some
purposeful screening of some of these
varieties with some of these potential
pathogen problems it's been mentioned a
couple of times about cropping rotations
and as a plant pathologist that's that's
a center focus for me as not only can
the organism survive in the soil or
potentially come in with the seed but in
many cases some of these organisms will
survive on the debris that's left behind
in the field and that be the bridge from
run growing season to another and coming
back what I said about the specificity
of many of these crop diseases so for
instance if we were planting this crop
after a grain crop like corn or
something like that or a small grain
there'd be very very few organisms would
interact and cause problems on those two
crops the closer they are related so we
could expect some dicot plants to be a
little more closely related to the
Hampton than some of our monocots so
we're going to be looking over time to
see if there's any carryover of some of
these pests one that does concern me
long term and has been a problem in
Canada and some other places is white
mold it's a fungal problem that is
already quite rampant and our Legg yum
crops
and some of our other broadleaf
vegetable crops so in soybean production
probably our biggest disease problem
right now is its glare Kenya white bulb
and that's a very broad host range
fungus and it survives survival
structures of the fungus called
sclerotia they will survive in the soil
for a number of years and so certainly
white mold is something we'll be looking
at in the Hamptons particularly in
rotations that would include vegetable
beings dry beans soybean highly
susceptible crops to white mold so
rotations are very important in this
sense as well so I don't want to talk at
you a lot here I want to make you aware
that that we're very interested in
learning more first of all what the
diseases and potential disease problems
might be and obviously a long term
interest is how to manage those I will
mention two people from my program Kevin
Myers
in the back year and Jamie Cummings will
be working in our lab to do a lot of the
diagnosis and of potential disease
problems and work with this with this
new crop so we would be appreciative of
anybody seeing anything in their fields
and letting us know we'd be glad to
diagnose problems in our laboratory get
out in your fields and look so please
please keep us informed and let us know
how how we can be of help to you so
another thing just to quickly say that
one of the main advantages against
diseases is just the vigorous rapid
growth of this crop and that's one of
the things I've learned from talking to
colleagues in other places yeah we see
some leaf spots yeah we see some of this
and that but the crop
basically outgrows them and and that is
an advantage with this crop and that
it's timely planted in appropriate soils
another thing we're not weed scientists
in our in our program but kevin has been
taking some notes in the various plots
about weed density and you know a great
take-home
here is is a tremendous correlation
between the weed density in these plots
and what the original stand was from the
emergence success in emergence of those
plots so the best defense against weeds
especially in the absence of any
herbicides to use is just to have a good
crop establishment have a good initial
stand and very often that this will be
sufficient to out-compete the weeds so a
pretty good strategy if you can do that
and any questions or comments some
observations others have made yet please
what is the closest normal plant in New
York that family relationship to him and
if you would say hops ok house would be
the cold you then say that whatever
attack hops diseases are pests and
similarly probably going to only is a
very general statement even within a
plant family there's tremendous
specificity in EM these pathogens there
are some things that would be candidates
that way a lot of the things that attack
through the soil the water molds of his
area rhizoctonia of some of these things
and tend to have a fairly wide host
range a lot of the leaf spotting type
organisms are really rather specific and
I think things like the downy mildew
Chris would be pretty separate from the
hops and and the the hamp in this case
so the more the more pathogen is
specialized the you know the less we
worry about that for related crops but
definitely that's something we'd be
looking at and there are some candidate
things we'd be looking at but I still
come back to white mold being the
biggest concern that way because it's a
very broad host range the weeds as well
as cultivated crops
anybody observe anything and you're on
your farms at this point okay we'll keep
us in mind if we help yeah
during regard to some of the pests farm
viability is funding
in Gilbert Jenkins at Morrisville with
some plots this summer specifically to
look at insect pests I don't notice you
doing much with diseases but standing
with insects I had some good information
Chris Becker has been interacting with
her and we have had a few things arrived
at either Chris's lab or mine in
connection with that but yeah we would
absolutely love to plug in with that and
get all the learning we can out of out
of these plots that are established and
we've also provided funding for he's
planning to do a statewide trial next
summer fertilization and health and ten
different farms around the state very
interesting we provided some funding for
Biden see already for that that's good
to know thank you thank you now would
you like to say a few things about what
insects that you know so again Elson
shields has been working on this he's in
our anthem ology Department but
unfortunately it was not able to make it
here after all but he did send me a list
of a few insects that he's observed in
the hemp around the state so far one of
them is unlike us bug it's maybe a
quarter inch big bug there that eats the
growing tips of the of the plant but
also the reproductive parts the floral
parts of the plant which obviously could
be very critical on the green types or
dual-purpose types there so that's one
of the things that he's keeping a watch
on another insect which is actually
prevalent on a lot of species is potato
leaf hopper and we have problems with
that owner alfalfa
if we don't spray an insecticide or use
the resistant variety but apparently
he's been seeing it on an industrial
hemp as well a third one that he
mentioned is thrips that's a very very
small insect but that can get into a
floral parts the pollen and so forth and
some of the things ellison didn't
mention it but some of the things that
i've read is that people are suspecting
that some of the major insect problems
on corn could actually be a problem one
hemp to I don't know the validity of
that or whether people are speculating
at this point but things like corn
armyworm and some others there so so it
is critical that entomologist be
bucking just like Jerry does with the
diseases there that we have entomologist
looking at insect problems so that we
know what challenges that we have in
front of us so if you have question
about insects I probably can't answer
them but you can ask the insect pressure
would build over time but there's more
crop available absolutely same for
diseases and insects yes as the acreage
increases across the state certainly
there's potential for more problems to
be there as well between other questions
comment okay so I'm going to turn this
over then to dr. Alan Taylor one of the
problems that we've already been
confronted with there's one of these
varieties in here which i think is this
short one is at jamee that had low
germination one of these was anyway was
it down there okay but one of the
varieties was from seed that was a year
older than the rest of them and the
germination rate was really low and even
though Jamie compensated with that to
have the same number of pure live seeds
per square foot so that we're comparing
apples and apples and not apples and
oranges still the stand density was not
as great as some of the other varieties
so the seeds important as gary said we
need to get a good stand establishment
so we're very pleased that dr. Alan
Taylor from the horticultural section in
the school of integrated plant science
is working on the seed aspect of this
well thanks Don for the introduction as
Chris mentioned there's a number of
states that have really of doing
research on hemp and a colleague of mine
from North Dakota State as an agronomist
was given a talk last year and really
talking about seed quality issues stand
establishment issues a lot of these seed
related things in my program here at
Cornell at the Geneva AG Experiment
Station we interact with a lot of
different crops vegetable crops but also
industrial crops so I thought at the
time I said this would be really a good
project for my laboratory to get
involved in and then here less than a
year later here we are
whereas Chris is we have this Cornell
hemp team it's really a consortium of
faculty with a wide range of X
40 silk and of focus on this I think
we're going to be able to make quite a
bit of progress in a relatively short
amount of time is where we're working on
this also as Chris mentioned really good
partnership with Ag markets and things
like that and being able to kind of work
at the regulatory level with this and
getting it out as well as the research
and the outreach that we're really so
good at here at Cornell we obviously see
as we're looking at here that that would
seed obviously the plant breeding and
genetics has a key role in what the
plant growth and development is but
another key aspect of seed is is the
seed quality and really the Quality
Assurance as you're buying seed if
you're spending that at least $50 an
acre to establish it's a major input
into growing a really a field crop like
as an agronomy crop is hemp would be so
you want to make sure that you're really
first of all getting the good quality
seed as right now for these trials we
have all the the the grain types or the
multi-purpose types here and there's
also other trials for the fiber types we
have 17 seed lots that we're working on
about half of those are from Canada the
rest are from Europe from Eastern Europe
Poland Ukraine over to Italy France or
the production of the origin of those
seeds so we're looking at a pretty good
kind of cross-section of commercial seed
all those seeds have to be imported here
into the United States so there are
aspects that really need to be addressed
as far as the quality for that sort of
Commerce coming into this country
there's really two aspects of seed
quality we always think of all the seeds
gotta germinate to grow definitely the
case but another aspect especially those
that are not involved with agronomic
crops or different seeded crops is what
we call the seed purity what the purity
is is if you're buying a bag of seed and
that could be a bag of wheat could be a
bag of hemp seeds is what else is in
that bag you want for example down there
you want the hemp the anchor variety but
what else could be in that bag
there could be weed seeds present there
could be other crop seeds present and
also what we just generically call it's
inert materials as other materials could
be broken seeds trash materials stones
things like that so in the 17th seed
lots that were working with now Michael
Luce who's their works in my program he
was the former manager of a New York
State seed testing laboratory and the C
testing laboratories now moved to Albany
but with Michaels actually running the
the germination and the purities on
those we're seeing some of these seed
Lots and again I don't have enough data
right now we're still doing this to have
as a handout some of these over 5% inert
material so basically we say it's pretty
trashy seed that we're getting again
somebody's buying this you want to make
sure that you're getting good quality
seed but probably the two keys that
we're really concerned about in this
purity on weed seeds for us to import
seeds to receive the seeds there has to
be an APIs permit conducted whether we
call a noxious weed examine not just
weeds are seeds which are really defined
by law that are harmful to agriculture
so you don't want to have those in the
bag because you're also planting those
and also just other common weed seeds
things like that that may also be
present so so we're going through these
samples right now in just kind of
testing trying to get as much
information on the quality aspect for
example with the Canadians seed Lots
that we've gotten is there close
partners to us they have their seed
certification system just like fill has
a seed certification program here the
basis of the two programs are the same
as we look at seed certification they
have different levels they have a
certification number one level and
number two so how do those differ they
really differ based on the quality the
level one is a high quality seed is so
the germination needs to be 85 percent
or higher and just to weed seeds can be
present in just one other crop seed and
25 grams sample where these other crop
seeds come in from you ask we do we do
not have
herbicide that can be used in the seed
production field so if there was outs
and we've seen oats as contaminants as
other crop seeds sunflower a lot of
those seeds are also coming over in your
seeds so again we want that to be as
clean as possible just as we've again
let's use a criteria with the 85%
germination and the 70% germination of
the 17th seed Lots that is being tested
within the Cornell system this year only
five of those had 85 percent germination
and higher so again we really need to
have high quality seeds for that good
initial stand establishment nine of
those which is about half had over 70%
so so again what you know when this
event up to be a commercial crop what
you're getting is very important because
that really starts the basis for that so
that's kind of where we're right now is
in this sake characterization the
Quality Assurance aspect to make sure
that the farmer ultimately has
high-quality seed the next part is it's
already been mentioned there are issues
early germination events early seedling
emergence stand establishment issues
with the hemp crop and again I learned
from this from my colleagues and
out-of-state so this is not a New York
problem it's not unique to us they have
the problems in Canada they have it
throughout the seeds and themselves I'll
just say I just have generally a low
vigor they tend to be weak germinate
errs once they get going you can see
they grow like heck but that early phase
which is a very very sense of the phase
and we need to get the plant
establishment again for that crop to
canopy which is providing the weed
management as well so so everything
really rotates I'm getting off to a good
start with the hemp seed now since we're
not able to use labels of chemical
pesticides including chemical seed
treatments then my laboratory is
interested
the research point of view of looking at
some development of some technology so
that'll be kind of where we're going
with our research two areas one is Gary
mentioned a lot of the the damping off
organisms that you're going to be
ubiquitous in our soils here Pistons
things like that what sort of a seed
treatment could we use not a chemical
seed treatment like a captain or thigh
ram or an apron but what else could we
use that we could still apply and so
we're kind of going to our tool box
where I work with organic vegetable seed
productions in that seed production but
seed quality as well and so what can we
take from that area as an organic seed
treatment so that's an area that we're
going to be moving into that so we can
get some of protection from some of
these early attacking early soil borne
pathogens the second aspect is again
they are inherently low vigor seeds and
again we don't know enough yet to really
to be able to really define the vigor
except doing a germination test but
we're relying on on people that have
worked in this crop for a long time so
in that regards again kind of some other
work that we're doing is what we're
calling bio stimulus by no stimulants or
compounds these are not pesticides that
are applied to plants to enhance plant
growth and development so we've already
done worked with seed treatments with
some of these biostimulant type of
materials natural type of materials no
pesticidal effect on them at all
what would they do to a hemp seed so
again you know we have a lot to do ahead
of us so we'll be ready for next growing
season to actually to test some of these
things but that kind of gives you in
kind of a quick summary where the seed
Science and Technology program is at the
Geneva Experiment Station with Cornell
focusing right now in the seed testing
aspects seed quality just to make sure
we can characterize the seed Lots that
we're working with but then the future
research and development really kind of
rolling up our sleeves and developing
some very practical seed treatments that
could be used
the hemp seeds to enhance plants
stablishment and early season growth
thank you any questions along the seed
line yes I'm surprised by the
substantial reduction in germination
from that 2017 to 2015 last was my
understanding was that 2015 dollars the
one that we have the seeding rate
adjusted and I'm wondering if that's
somewhat more unique perhaps maybe
because of the high oil content most
other crops I'm familiar with which
showed such a dramatic difference
between one year as long as that he was
handled a really good question and we're
looking at the issues of seed quality
but also in the case if we have
carryover seeds things like that there
are kind of as we look kind of across
the board of seeds some seeds are just
naturally short-lived seed like a
soybean happens to be a short-lived seed
other crops just tend to be like a
tomato seed is a very long live so
there's just sort of like my lifespan
compared to you know my pet dog the dog
has a shorter natural lifespan than I do
so you have some of that so so the hemp
kind of fits into that as far as just a
genetic basis it is a high oil content
seeds but some seeds so there's not a
strict rule of thumb on oil content for
example the tomato seeds which is a very
long live see it's a very high oil or
lipid content seed so there's a lot of
things we really don't know but but from
again kind of what we have seen is that
this storage especially in a carryover
situation can be an issue and so for
example these companies that we've
talked about up in Canada the seeds that
they're producing last year the seeds
that were using so they're produced
harvested they have to be carried over
of these three seed lots of anka that we
got all the same variety three different
seed lines from this is from their
germination conducted up in Canada from
tour in the upper 80s one is in a 70 and
I said why you know in a nice sort of a
way why
did that happen are these Kerry overseas
they said no they're all harvested one
was harvested a little later and may
have had a little bit higher moisture
content that went into that overwinter
storage that higher moisture the seeds
are just going to age faster so so there
is just so you can't even say variety of
how things are going to respond you
really have to look at the seed lot
level but even like I said an example
where we have lots and lots of that
seeds for the commercial use this year
there are differences between those
three seed lots and again they are
attributed just to that it's higher
moisture content we can check that
moisture content we have you know we can
we can look at that but after the aging
has happened and seed so there's nothing
we can't go retro on this but but at
least we can characterize that it's
knowing what the the moisture should be
safe storage very good question thank
you yes sir moisture content is actually
created by when you harvest early
harvest more moisture too late others
less moisture as an example is that was
that possible so so what is going on
during seed development in the later
phases of seed development is is the
seed on the mother plant is drying down
what they would like to do is ideally
harvest at the right moisture content
and then that could go right into
storage however if it is immature seed
it's going to have a higher moisture or
if it's rained or so as so sow that seed
moisture is just going up and down with
whatever the environment is going on so
if it's a high relative humidity if
there's wetness it's going to be picking
up moisture from there so the ideal
thing is you want to harvest at the
right moisture content and then go into
the storage and things like that I only
have some things that I've written but
we've not actually characterized that so
I don't want to I don't want to
speculate on that right now but thank
you that's it's a it's a good point
because again is generally when when
we're in more of the seed where the seed
buyer right now New York is not a seed
producer we really are relying on what
has happened upstream with the seed
companies what they've done with seed
processing or what we call seed
conditioning sorting the seed
doing things like that and as I and I
just want to add one other point on seed
size again as we're doing this purity we
look at the seeds we're also taking we
have a thousand seed weight or thousand
kernel weight they call it but you do
see varietal differences some are just
larger seeds others but even with in the
sample we have there's a large
difference in seed size they're small
seeds medium see slides large seeds and
again we want uniformity of germination
we want uniformity of stand
establishment that does not set us on
the right foot if we're already starting
off with a wide range of seed sciences
within the same seed lot so again
something else something else we need to
kind of look at a little bit there - any
other guesses so just to get your other
grain and extra crops you have seed the
foundation here that checks for quality
is to be a nurse and everything else
cookie it looks like to have two kind of
a roll introduction to there to the seed
industry and I would suspect it
importing these peas from other
countries
number two green you're going to have
those imperfections you're going to have
those variations so I'm assuming APIs AG
and markets seed foundation they're
going to work at developing some basic
standards for the theater is just going
to be a open format whatever whatever
comes in what multiple points that
you're making and all really really good
us because the bottom line is we want to
assure a New York grower that's going to
be planning the hemp that they have good
quality seed I think if we look at
Canada Canada started this nineteen
ninety eight so they've been doing
they've been growing him for many years
in these seed companies I would say are
pretty mature they're not Mon pod type
of companies that are just you know
going out here whacking some seeds off
and threshing them out and sell them now
these these are big operations and when
we're buying you know a seven hundred
and fifty kilogram totes of those that
are coming in that's a big seed
production facility that they have I've
not seen it but it's there they're very
mature in that
they've also have their own seed
certification standards for example to
make that number one certified has to
have the high germination of 85 or
better but just a few seeds now if it
turns out and say just one other crop
seed and then to weed seeds if that
sample they pull has for weed seeds in
it even though the germination is 90% it
drops it down automatically to their
certified level number to the grower
doesn't really know that they just know
it's it's a level 2 certification it's
lower grade they don't know why they
have but but we can track that down and
know so so I think in in their system
they're using both the purity as a
criteria for high quality and the
germination and it's real it's real well
it's it's a good system it's a little
different than what we do here in the
state but it is a good system so you
know if you're getting that number one
certified that you're getting very good
seed yes sir so the numbers you gave us
earlier on the rates of germination and
those were provided by the vendor at
their certified levels okay there's two
things so when I talked about the anchor
the three seed lots of anchor I don't
even have the third seed light yeah
everything is pretty pretty new and then
it's it's not only 50 miles from for
Mystica to Geneva but it's just
cumbersome I'll just put it that way and
moving seeds around even within the
Cornell system so we have not done any
of the testing on these three anchor lot
what I'm saying is we do have samples
from all of these types along with four
other fiber types that is where we did
the actual germination and we're doing
the purity right now where we're that
new into this when we have this field
day two weeks from today in Geneva I'm
going to be able to talk more than I can
now just because we're you know we're
generating the data as we speak that's
that's ultimately what I want to be able
to do yeah is is we're taking out of a
little baggie a sample compared to them
going through their large inventory so
we want to make sure that what we're
saying is representative not that
anybody's right or wrong it's just being
really representative yeah exactly
good
yes death I'm not sure if there's patent
laws or things like that surrounding
speed so say somebody took a top of
headed one of your plants here and took
the seed and replanted they were kind of
questions with their deeds those are
more the legal aspects and kind of
talked about some of that
that's basically it it's not leaked you
be dealing with trespass in addition to
the night you know are there some
hopeful motor issues around doing
something like right so I was well done
Jamie's really did a yeoman's job of
doing this Jimmy head of talking
acquiring the seats for Cornell okay
okay perfect perfect stay tuned and
we'll get that question answer for you
yes sir did you do a moisture test on
the incoming seed from Canada so you
know what we level was there we have not
gathered that data but we do have with
the samples that are still in the
original bag so we can go ahead and
sample out of that what we're really
concerned about is when we get a small
when you get a hundred gram sample which
is like a cup full of seeds and that's
an open porous container and it's a
humid day or a dry day that's all going
to change so we really need to go back
is the best we can do that and then take
a deep core out of that then we will
have a more representative but yeah as
you know as every this whole season kind
of progressed and getting things there's
a lot of what it could as should as and
they're always isn't doing research but
this was really a hurry-up type of a
year to get as far as we are right now I
think next year we'll be more in place
with doing those quality right as soon
as we receive the seeds excellent point
we need to be really good seedsman here
on our site as well okay yes ma'am you
up the wall will be plenty of PHP and
CBBC
profile has they been tested
and it available anywhere for us so we
can know what THC quantity here what CBD
and what types of CBD is a CBD AC maybe
just DVD do you have these varieties
from testify yes that's all to be done
correct
did you hear the question and all the
varieties been tested sorry for THC and
CBD levels and varieties are going
strong here will test here but in Canada
there's actually a really informative
website like Ontario Canada fact sheets
and they have fact sheets that covered
lots and lots of different things and
one of the things they have is a list a
variety and those they found to be low
or high THC content and I can't remember
off the top of my head if they have CBD
in there as well but that's a very
informative site plan thank you really
really good questions and again there's
a lot of unsolved questions but we are
addressing these so so thank you very
much for your comments and questions
okay thank you I want to you guys okay
so so our last speaker is Chris Logue
who really appreciate came the long
distance I mean most of us are right
here on campus or with a little over an
hour away but Chris came quite a
distance from Albany to be here Chris is
the director of the division of planned
industry in the New York State
Department of Agriculture markets and
he'll be talking about some of these
regulatory issues like the question that
was asked as well as potential markets
here so thank you very very much for the
opportunity to be here today I know I'm
going to get lots of questions so I'm
glad I don't have notes but I'm going to
follow I'm just going to start out a
little bit and tell you sort of how we
got here
gary described himself as a student of
hemp diseases i have become a student of
hemp it's been the school of hard knocks
there's some people sitting out here
that have been very very helpful to me
in learning about this crop so it's been
couple of years that we've been working
on hemp and as all of you know we
started out at the department with a
pretty conservative program that limited
our research partners or limited
research permits to folks who were
affiliated with colleges and
universities and institutions of higher
education this spring we were able to
open it up and bring some farmers into
it and some other folks and then of
course added a number of research
partners with the anka trial this summer
so we're definitely sort of on the track
towards a more liberal approach to this
I want to talk a little bit about you
know the authority for any of us to be
doing this so the authority for any of
us to be engaged in this comes from the
2014 Farm Bill
and basically what the 2014 farm bill
did and I'll just paraphrase basically
it enabled universities or institutions
of higher education and state
departments of Agriculture to engage in
industrial hemp research pilot programs
so I'm a good side the farm bill doesn't
define what a pilot research program is
and it doesn't necessarily define what
commercialization is that in a way is
sort of a double-edged sword it's a good
thing it's not defined it lets us sort
of figure out what the boundaries are
but I think the other thing that you
need to keep in mind if this is
something that you're considering doing
that at some point along the way
somebody might say hey you're up against
the fence you're going too far okay and
we are dealing quite a bit with
Department of Justice and DEA and I have
to tell you they've been extremely
helpful to us I think they've been
pretty responsive with Cornell and SUNY
Morrisville but this is out of the
ordinary for them they regulate
controlled substances from cradle to
grave in the case of hemp they regulate
the seed and then they step away from it
so this is new territory for them as
well the other piece that I'll
throw out there is that the farm bill
will be up for renewal or renegotiation
and 2018 and so we need to be aware that
you know there could potentially be some
changes in that language in the farm
bill and so that's one of the things
that's on my tick list from a policy
perspective working with some of our
policy folks in Albany and in Washington
DC to make sure that we can continue to
move forward so going forward with the
2018 farm bill you could see the same
language that was in 2014 you could see
a step back away from that that maybe
restricts us more or you could see from
a federal level maybe some
liberalisation so we need to be aware of
that from the policy perspective the
other thing I'll say on the federal side
is is that you know we had some very
high-level discussions with some of the
federal folks and again they are frankly
they don't answer a lot of questions
directly so if you start asking me
questions about federal policy I'm
probably going to be a little cagey too
there is also if you go on our website
you know you can you can check out a
number of documents that are very very
important from a from a regulatory and
an authority perspective the three
things that I would say you want to be
looking at and be aware of on the
federal level are the wording of the
2014 farm bill the wording in the 2016
Omnibus Budget Act it's very important
as well and then the third piece is is a
guidance document from I think July or
August of last year that came out from
DEA FDA and USDA so those are sort of
the three guiding documents that are out
there there's still a whole lot of gray
in this what we've tried to do as we've
moved forward with this is to build a
program that is if you will a safe
harbor for folks who want to get
involved in this we want to try to keep
you as farmers growers processors what
have you sort of in a safe place from
the federal perspective but at the same
time trying to move this ahead and learn
as much as we possibly can
one thing I do want to actually make
sure everybody knows tape in the back
there Kate
is the person who if you call our office
and you call the temp 800 number that
was announced a few weeks ago you will
most likely talk with Kate and she will
if she can't answer your question she's
going to take down your information and
get it get the question to somebody who
can help you so bear with us on that
we're sort of building this as we go I
want to make a just a quick comment on
the trial behind me here this is
probably the best attempt I've seen not
that I've seen a lot but I was in
Kentucky a couple of weeks ago for the
hemp regulatory conference and we were
on several farms and basically we were
hearing all the same things that all the
Cornell faculty have said today seed
quality emergence competition with weeds
a lack of herbicides if you're if you're
in a situation where you would use an
herbicide or another crop protectant on
this we're we're coming up against all
the same issues that have been I've been
identified in other states so we're
learning a lot as we go along so a
little bit about the process going
forward I from us from an administrative
perspective I've kind of felt for the
last two-and-a-half years like I've been
a little bit behind the curve on the
timing on this and so we're always
trying
we're always on a scramble to get things
done and so our goal going forward this
year is for 2018 I should say is to try
to roll out the application process very
very soon and so I'm going to throw some
dates out there please don't come call
me if this doesn't come true and give me
a hard time
I'd like it to open up for applications
during the month of August
that's this month probably towards the
end of the month because we've got some
vacations and some other professional
meetings that we our staff are engaged
in and what that would do is basically
we
probably leave that application period
open for several months maybe into the
middle or end of October that's going to
give folks adequate time to develop
their research plan and again I keep
circling back around to that farm bill
that allows us to do research not
commercialization so the thing that I'm
going to weigh most heavily on an
application is what's your research plan
what are you going to be able to bring
to the table to offer as far as new
knowledge or knowledge gained and that
again we take a very very broad approach
to research it can be agronomic it can
be pest management it can be marketing
it can be product development you name
it you can probably make the argument
that it's research
so basically getting that out there
August September October of this year is
going to give you folks time to develop
a good plan it's going to give you time
to start talking with your seed
suppliers in Canada the European Union
wherever you decide you're going to get
your seed from it also gives us a little
bit more time we actually applied for
our DEA import permit on March 17th of
this year and the DEA came out I think
on June 27th or something and they
interviewed several of us they took all
of our personal information names of our
eldest children where they were located
all that kind of good stuff
and so we're waiting on our permit so
next year hopefully that permit will be
in place soon I'd like it to be in place
before we go out with our application
for 2018 I don't know if that's
realistic or not so once that permit is
in place that's going to give us the
opportunity at the department to play
the role of the importer so what that
means is if you were a research partner
with the department in 2018 you would
figure out what seed variety you wanted
or varieties you wanted you would talk
with the seed company candidate the
european union wherever
and make all the arrangements financial
shipping what have you to get the seed
into the country and when it's imported
it would be delivered to Albany and at
that point you would come to Albany and
pick it up we would release it to you so
that's kind of what we're looking at
going forward so we're hoping for a much
more streamlined process definitely
invested in this I want to be as helpful
as we can to folks a couple things from
the processing perspectives that was the
other thing that I was asked to talk
about today so two things I think I want
to sort of talk a little bit about sort
of what I think of what's going on in
the industry
I kind of look at the two major issues
that I think are facing us almost Alera
almost like a set of bookends you got
the seed issue okay and we've talked
about a lot of the physical attributes
of the seed as far as seed quality
emergence all that type of thing you
have the political of the regulatory
aspects of it where can you get it it's
hard to get into the country
okay need a lot of permits so if this
industry is going to move forward I
think the plant breeding program and
getting a domestic seed supply and when
I say domestic seed supply I mean the
seed supply within the borders of New
York State where this product is under
the state's authority is really really
important I'm not a plant breeder but I
do have a background in horticulture I
think we all have to realize that's not
going to happen overnight okay I've had
a bunch of questions here and I heard
some questions here today about feral
stands of hemp and so that's definitely
something that's sort of on our radar
screen we got to understand what that
what that is
so that federal hemp it's out there that
could be that could be something else
we don't know probably hasn't been
tested for THC number one number two we
need to understand what the genetics of
it are
so it could be the foundation for a
really good breeding program or it might
be something that we don't want okay and
so it's going to take some time to
understand what that is okay the other
bookend that I think is really really
important is the processing and the
marketing okay so that's the other thing
that is potentially a little bit risky
and where we need to do a lot more work
and have a better understanding of what
this what this plant and what this
industry can do and you know there's
some of you here that have known me for
a while I was in extension for over 20
years and actually this isn't very much
different than any other crop I talked
with a hemp farmer the other day and I
said hey I'm going to tell you the exact
same thing I talked to people 20 years
about strawberries green house flowers
whatever we can teach you how to grow
this but we can't necessarily teach you
how to sell it how to market it that
part of it you guys have to really sort
of take the ball and run with that to a
certain extent so what we're working on
as far as marketing is concerned is we
have in our division of Ag development
we have some staff who do work on
marketing efforts and we're at least
taking the step of moving forward
identifying processors within the state
of New York
because again relatively easy if you've
got some hemp product you can and
relative with relative ease move it
about within the borders of the state
we're also identifying processors
outside the state of New York and so at
least we'll have a resource list
available to you that folks can look at
and then the other thing is I believe
yesterday or the day before Empire State
Development came out with some processor
grants so there are some funds available
to help to spur the processing industry
and so if you call us at the department
and talk with Kate I'm pretty sure you
do have a you've got a contact person at
ESD now so we have someone we can we can
refer you to feed certification yes
thank you the other thing that's on
tick list coming out of the bill signing
in the summit and really related to my
comments about developing a domestic
within the borders of New York seed
industry one of the things that we
really have high on our list to do is to
develop some seed certification
standards so we've got if you look in
the AG and markets law
there are seed certification standards
for all kinds of different crops that we
grow we work closely with the folks here
New York State seed improvement and
Cornell when we develop those standards
but that's going to be very very
important and really what it comes down
to as dr. Taylor said and a nutshell is
sort of consumer protection for the
people who are buying that seed okay and
that's really going to set the set the
stage for developing that industry along
with development of some genetics that
are good for New York as well as good
for the various uses of industrial hemp
with that I can answer some questions
I'm sure there will be some there always
are yes sir
one of the political pressure points
that can be used to make sure it's
motivated in a favorable direction so
the question was in regards to the 2018
farm bill what are the pressure points
as far as a favorable outcome you know I
think one of the things with anything at
a federal level and again hemp is a very
small piece of well actually not it's a
very large piece of what I've been doing
over the last couple of years but we've
got a lot of other issues where we're
dealing with the federal government and
I would just say in general there's a
lot of anxiety among sort of middle
management folks in in federal agencies
not necessarily a great deal of
direction I would say one thing that we
may have from a favorable perspective is
Kentucky is a big state in hemp and so
you have Mitch McConnell with a
leadership position and
bombers and so that potentially you know
helps with the whole hemp situation but
I think you know try trying to predict
what the pressure points are is it's
pretty hard with how things have been
have been working at the federal level
at this point so the question is is that
on the New York delegation and I think
there's been a quite a bit of interest
from from the New York delegation from
my perspective Donna do us something you
want to add to that yep so we were just
with Senator Gillibrand recently and she
is one of the main sponsors of the 2015
industrial hemp farming act so our hope
is that because of the interest from
largely from Kentucky Rand Paul and
Mitch McConnell and others and the
widespread support in places across the
country where it's growing that we can
get around those treasure points by
Death pressuring for full passage of
legalization we think that is looking
much more likely than it's ever before
I'm not positive how many of our New
York congressman it's only done last
year I think we had five and our
congressman had just recently retired so
he's my own bill at the moment but yeah
that's our goal the goal is to pass the
industrial and farming act and just make
everybody's life a lot easier
the county's intestinal thank you yes
sir yeah question regarding the farm
bill why there was so much effort by the
DEA and play on words when it comes to
the CBD extract part of the plant
they try to make it like its THC we know
it's not THC they play around a lot of
words and I've read you talking about
the recent elderly know not just the
response we scheduled but also as part
of the forum act they're trying to
delineate the CBD and it doesn't sound
favorable like that so a couple things
is there are even in some states and as
I said I was in Kentucky two weeks ago
for the regulatory conference which
basically was pretty much limited to
folks from State Department's of
Agriculture there were a few extension
people there as presenters as well so it
was a pretty open exchange in forum and
even some of the states have defined
industrial hemp as grain and fiber only
and have limited CBD research at the
federal level I think there's again a
little bit of a disconnect
perhaps if you will because some of
those products have not necessarily had
clinical trials on them and so there's a
hesitancy to move forward with them and
again I kind of would go back and I'm
not going to you know poke another
agency DEA has been pretty helpful to us
DEA has been pretty helpful
I think the Cornell in lawrenceville I
think going back to my previous
statement regulatory officials look for
black and white and there's not a lot of
black and white in this and so when you
have a DEA investigator or someone in a
leadership position at DEA and it
doesn't fit neatly into how they defined
other substances they really struggle
with that and so I think it's sort of a
discovery or a process of trying to
figure out you know what's what we've
taken a little bit more liberal approach
on the sea
the end of things but we've also had a
lot of discussions with our State
Department of Health over the past six
months about CBD and you know they're in
a role where they're going to be backing
us up on a technical perspective because
as I say to my boss do you want an
entomologist a forester and somebody
with a dairy science background to be
evaluating projects that might have
medical or health implications out of my
wheelhouse you start to talk to me about
the agronomy or the pest management I
can probably look at that pretty easily
and tell if it's a good project a worthy
project if I have questions I have
probably 11 right folks at Cornell who
can help me out with that you start
getting into some of the CBD stuff and
start to make health claims and that
type of thing and even to some extent
nutritional claims will necessarily have
the backstop for that right now and so
we're developing that but you a good
based on that line um of what we're
deciding about now what is New York
State
definition on a medical CBD marijuana
versus what I'm looking at right now
which is camp with CBD oil in it right
what's the difference there is it a gray
area so thank you for saying it's a gray
area because it is a gray area we're
trying to figure that out you know one
of the things that's a little bit of a
challenge is is so within the Medical
Marijuana Program there are very strict
quality control standards in there very
strict production standards that's not
stuff that we have in the industrial
hemp current industrial hemp regulations
it's not something that frankly is in
the next iteration of the industrial
hemp regulations but we're working on
trying to define where those regulatory
boundaries are and and when other
agencies have to be brought in so we you
know we don't want to get in trouble
when we don't want anybody that's
sitting here in the audience they get in
difficulty with either another state
agency or a federal agency and so I
think a little bit of patience a little
bit of working through it and we'll
certainly get there yes
hello experienced men have and marijuana
and medical marijuana as a police
officer I might not be confused by some
of these color varieties but I
definitely would be confused with the
Collard variety is not just based on its
local based on
texture and that essentially there's not
real there's a gray area so is egg and
markets when people are applying for
these applications helping them reach
out to their local at least to make sure
that they're aware I know we have a size
but my neighbors probably read that side
and just report me for growing marijuana
so so the question was what about you
know working with law enforcement as far
as on industrial hemp and so I don't
have the regulations in front of me but
basically what we currently have in the
regulations and definitely is going into
the next version is a requirement for
when you get your industrial hemp
research authorization from the
department you have a certain amount of
time to reach out to your local law
enforcement agency and let them know
that you have this permit okay and so
each of the original ten authorization
holders have done that and they report
back to us that they've completed it
oftentimes they send us a copy of the
letter or give a reference to a phone
call or what have you that happened and
interestingly enough we've gotten
questions on it we had somebody actually
call in and it came I don't think it
came to my desk I think it came to Tim's
desk and came to his desk as you have an
industrial hemp call well it was a
County Sheriff
and a fisherman had scampered up from
the riverbank and apparently had walked
some distance from where he started
fishing and he came up and something
that looked like this and he called the
call the police and so you know that
particular authorization holder had
talked with somebody within the County
Sheriff's Department but it kind of word
hadn't gone through the whole
organization so we were able to take
that call and answer it we also have had
calls from New York State Police
intelligence unit because some of our
authorization holders have sent the
license and the license looks like our
plant life plant industry plant dealer
or plant grower license and when you
photocopy it the secure
favor the watermark doesn't show up and
so they rightfully questioned whether it
was really the real deal or not did you
want to add something Donna should
things just for for reference in Vegas
University has 15,000 CBD rich plants in
the ground in a raised bed format
they're doing a different type of grow
their plants were imported as cuttings
from Kentucky his IP for static IP
protected material has been cut it cuts
and cloned and the local sheriff was
very interested to come and see what was
going on but we've had a cross board
support from law enforcement largely
because when they understand the issue
of cross-pollination this does have an
impact on legally grown marijuana which
makes them very happy none of us not so
much but some some people are not happy
about yes so and since Donna brought up
Kentucky I guess I should address that
issue so if you look at the program or
the if you look at the US Department of
Justice guidance and you look at the
USDA the the three agency guidance
document from a year ago it expressly
forbids the movement of plants and seeds
among states however there's another
document that says industrial hemp can
move among states that have programs
state authorized programs and so the
guidance document doesn't necessarily
have force of law behind it I will tell
you that the DEA is fully aware that
plants and seeds are coming from
Kentucky and Colorado and Oregon the
department's not going to facilitate
that but we are not at this point going
to forbid you from doing that I think
that we'll probably continue to be a
question that we wrestle with a little
bit you know some of the other states in
that we interface with down in Kentucky
basically we're saying well once you do
that you don't kind of know what you're
getting into your state and so
potentially you have some issues going
forward from a regulatory perspective so
if you do that you're doing it at your
own risk
and anybody who's a current
authorization holder has read all the
releases and sign the forms anybody
could applies you'll you'll see the
paperwork that's involved in this sir
one of my wife's Canadian relatives
involved in the health industry up there
he said a nightly occurrence car pulls
up jumps up at black a few bushes back
in the car and away they go as a grower
or possessor of hemp in New York through
this program what are my legal
responsibilities should that happen on
my farm go back to bed call the cops
this is getting out into the community
even one or whatever it is so first off
I'm not an attorney I'm a plant industry
director but what I would say is if I if
I held up if I held a research
authorization and that was happening I
would first for our regulation you've
already got a relationship with your
local law enforcement that's part of the
reason we want you to call if you have
our research authorization that's part
of the reason we want you to call local
law enforcement so they know it's there
so they maybe can drive by a little more
often if they want to keep an eye on
what's going on but also so you have a
relationship so I would say you want to
you want to call them and report it and
the other piece of it is is for
whoever's taking it they have no legal
protection once they cross the fence
okay if I cut one of these now and I
went outside across that fence I have a
controlled substance and so any law
enforcement officer because I'm not a
research authorization holder in the
program would have every right to stop
me so I would say you report it and
document that as well because one of the
things that you
potentially happens going forward is is
you potentially get into a situation
where your neighbor maybe doesn't like
this kind this form of Agriculture and
decides they want to challenge you on
that so you want to have a good you know
good records that you have been diligent
about controlling this product and
keeping it from getting where it
shouldn't be
it's there kind of a compound question
for you here Chris flowing from this one
how do you establish the the chain of
title or provenance of the product that
you have if you do apply or it by
appropriate means and your process or
etc you need to have a certification or
a bill of sale what documentation will
essentially qualify you to hold that
product and then convention earlier that
it's fairly easy to move this product
around within the state of New York that
suggests to me that it might be a little
bit but you also did say identifying
processors out-of-state okay so I'm
curious is it is it something where the
raw product Rothsay etc is more
difficult to send out of state once it's
processed into a product is that
relatively easier to send out sure so a
couple things so number one your first
question was sort of how do you how do
you establish the chain of title correct
and so what we've done up to now is is
that we have had our authorization
holders if they're sending a product to
processing
we've added that processor as a site
under their existing license I think
what we're going to do going forward is
to actually register processors and so
we don't envision the registration of
processors to have a fee attached to it
at this point in time it's basically
you're filing with us to say you are a
hemp processor that way if you are in
possession and really what concerns us
is if you were a processor and you're in
possession of any propagated material so
in other words seed that hasn't been
roasted or denatured or sterilized we
want to have the you as a processor have
a piece of paper in your hand that says
you're authorized to have that in the
event that federal officials came in and
you know asked why you had that product
the second part of your question once
again about the use of transporting
products prosity okay
so if you go back and again I don't have
the exact wording in my mind but if you
go back to the Controlled Substances Act
of 1970 it actually exempts certain
parts of the plant even right within the
Controlled Substances Act now one of the
things I will say it again I not in the
business of poking another agency
especially the DEA since I need to get a
permit from them right now they don't
have any if you and if you interpret the
Controlled Substances Act literally you
could make the interpretation that hemp
was never illegal it was just really
hard to get the permits for it in fact
nobody ever got the permits for it over
the past 50 years
so seed and plants probably pretty
difficult to get from state to state
that's going to pique the interest of
the DEA and I will tell you in in our
interviews they're well aware of what's
going on and have what I would say is
pretty good intelligence the other parts
of the plant should move very easily
among states that have an industrial
hemp program North Dakota I believe last
year ran into some problems where one of
their authorization holders had a large
amount of material and I don't can't
remember what part of the plant it was
that DEA held for a period of time and
the Department of Agriculture and the
DEA you know got into a into a war of
letters and eventually the product was
released and went to where it needed to
go so I think we're going to run into
some bumps like that from time to time
and again what happened last year which
was I believe in
was either in December or January and
talking sort of informally with my
counterpart in North Dakota his take on
it was there was an administration
change going on there was a lack of
clarity as to where this was going and
that somebody at a regional level had
decided to take advantage of that change
and try to make an example so to speak
so I think you know I think as we move
through the 2018 farm bill process we're
going to have a much better sense of
what the federal administration is
thinking and where we're going on this
yes ma'am if you're making tents on
forested land like I've had assessed on
forested party and this was a survivor I
think it's of course the Department of
the State Police
but you're passing them on your property
that's forested well let's say part of
it is forested in you planted England
who do you go to
in 2008 I think if you have a theft
issue and you're holding our you know if
you're holding our egg and markets
research authorization you would go to
your local law enforcement officials but
you would also want to be sure that we
at the department knew what was going on
as well so the current regulation and
again the current regulation that's on
the books we wrote those with the
research institutions in mind so frankly
they're a little bit outdated for where
we are right now as far as what's going
on in the state those original
regulations did have a specific signage
requirement and going forward that's not
going to be in the next iteration of the
regulations because you sort of have a
double-edged sword with signage it can
you put a no trespassing sign here I'm
not going to go in but if my wife saw a
no trespassing sign here she would go in
because she want to see what was in
there
we tested that years ago at the
Washington State governor's mansion and
the troopers took us out of there so you
know we got like three steps up the
driveway it's not like an Albany where
there's a gate anyway so you know
signage is really going to depend upon
your your situation you know driving up
and looking at this from the road I
could tell it was Hampton from the road
but I was working for him if I was
driving by here and had no idea that it
was here I would just think it was some
different field crop so a lots going to
depend upon upon your location the
signage was certain extent you know one
of our authorization holders said hey
we're putting an advertisement on this
and he wasn't concerned about the local
kids going in the field and stealing it
he was concerned about you know somebody
else within a five mile radius that was
perhaps growing something else and
didn't want the pollen from his crop to
contaminate and illicit grow and having
it be destroyed because of that yeah
is there any answer as to whether
farmer who's holding a federal program
benefit like through FFA can grow under
than your parents excellent question so
the question was can somebody who is
participating in some of the federal
some of the other federal programs like
Conservation Reserve or what have you
can they hold our permit and participate
without putting into jeopardy their
other payments and so we've been going
back and forth quite a bit with our
legal counsel on that and we don't
necessarily have a have a clear answer
on that our legal counsel that the
Department feels as though there's with
our research authorization there
shouldn't be a problem but that is not
to say that somebody at the county level
and an FSA or another federal office
couldn't hold something up so I think
that's something we're still working on
and trying to hammer that out and
perhaps you know perhaps that's
something from a policy perspective that
needs to be defined better in the farm
bill I do think the bill that was signed
here back a few weeks ago that the state
level reiterates the fact that this is
an agricultural commodity and I think
that may help a little bit with this but
we're sort of on untested waters on that
but it's a great question and one that
we heard a number of times and are
working on so thank you yes sir
we've got 131 states now you're involved
in research
is there any group lobbying effort on a
pulling on a federal level to look at
legislation for the 2018 farm bill I
mean our current Attorney General looks
probably not
can't camp friendly or sure I think you
mentioned one other workshop that he
sells everything Quixote so but I mean
what we forward I mean is as as the
state the multiple I thought that was
going to be one of the book the
cocaine's you were talking about yeah I
mean that one this that one is for sure
is is also in there so you know I've
been asked actually with that yesterday
to be sure to write up you know my
policy issues within plant industry for
the 2018 farm bill and you know was
encouraged to have several that related
to industrial hemp so I think we'll come
at it from that direction I also think
that the National Association of State
Department's of Agriculture will will
likely and that's basically the
commissioners and the state directors
and those types of folks at the highest
levels will probably have something from
a policy perspective and then you know
there's the hemp industries association
and some of the other like vote hemp who
I think will have some pressure from you
know the producer in the general public
side and Farm Bureau probably will as
well I don't know is that in their
policy manual with this policy book
sorry I got this time limit put in there
do we lobby and Albany ending Washington
and I make sure that I go because some
of those other people still don't
understand the difference between
marijuana in happen still legislators
like when you said they're about five
McDonough
that like there really weren't when I
brought it up people we're not in last
three years understanding it now it's
like they're like oh yeah I've heard
about this and we're going to keep going
and if you want to contact your County
Farm Bureau and help support that and
let them know that people are farmers
are interested in if they don't know
farmers are interested in that they're
not going to want you know we Farm
Bureau's reports with farmers on and if
they're not the only need from farmers
and they're not gonna want to support it
we know that I'm just the crazy lady no
no because I had a question we heard a
lot about seed protection and cloning
protection but what about it's a
perennial plan so how are we protecting
it from growing back perennial II like
if a farmer cousin sounds they with a
cyst and leaves the roots in the ground
there's a good chance that's going to
come back on its own or if they let it
go to seed and they don't collect all
those seeds before they hit the ground
there's a good chance that you can seed
itself so how how are we talking about
protection on that and like with apples
or other farm potties is there like a
statue limitations like an apple that is
cross bred they have a new Snapdragon
one I can plant it but I can't sell it
for ten years
and then I will be able to sell it as
whatever are there other things like
that for this offending outgrowth and so
I don't think we've really addressed
that at this point in time and perhaps
that's something you know I know that's
an issue because what I've learned is
when it goes through the combine it does
shatter and so you do have a lot of
receding during just during the
harvesting process so that is probably
something that we've got to address at
some point going forward yep
yes is there any interest in developing
a market for the herd and sending that
back in the ground and getting carbon
credits I know there's a lot of activity
in India and in Europe in the whole
market so we actually have an
authorization holder or current
authorization holder that has a piece of
that in their research plan to be
looking at that a little bit and I think
I think dr. V Ann's was talking a little
bit about the systematics person looking
at how it fits into a rotation and so
there may be some you know really good
agronomic and carbon credit issues you
know that are benefits in a rotation
even if you weren't going to the extent
of growing it for green or some other
purpose there is only a cap on how many
research license holders we're going to
be available for next year
so the cap was removed from the law so
what I would say to you is you know
we're still going to require an
application we're still going to require
the application fee it's $500 for three
years and we're still going to as long
as the farm bills in place and says it's
a research pilot program we're still
going to be evaluating proposals and you
know making sure that that the projects
that we that we give the authorizations
to you know have a research outcome
associated with them but we don't
anticipate a limited number now you know
the other piece of it I also need to be
protective of the fact that there are
many important missions that my division
is responsible for in New York State and
I have a limited number of people out
there to do this work and so we have
export certification and interstate
certification of many agricultural
products that are very lucrative for the
state of New York for our farmers we
need to make sure we fulfill that we
have plant pests and survey
responsibilities for invasive insects
and
diseases that would you know cause
damaged in the agriculture of New York
as well as the environment we have to
take that very very seriously
so I guess where I'm going is if I got
10,000 applications I probably can't or
give out 10,000 authorizations but what
we're hoping to do is create an
environment where we're learning as much
as we can going forward for the time
when maybe the industrial hemp farming
act sails through and if it's no longer
a regulated substance then our role is
diminished a great deal I would say from
a regulatory perspective the other part
that I'll just throw out there is I
think anybody who's involved in this for
the time being
with it being federally regulated as
well as regulated at the state level you
have to understand what it is that
you're growing you need to know your
seed source you need to know that it
does meet the 0.3 percent THC and you
need to do everything you know in your
power to protect yourself as well as
protect all the great work that's been
done to bring this from something that
everybody was scared to death of two
years ago to something where there's you
know 50 or 100 people under a tent that
if akka talking about it so Donnie you
want to make a comment on that I know
we're running one guy should make a
couple of quick summary comments but I
want to thank Cornell for putting this
together and really informative on did a
note it feel really good about being in
your state right now around this
compared to other states or maybe
permitting us and all the gears on in
motion as hard as it is to believe I
have to pinch myself tell her to put ten
million dollars down on the table for
processor grants of $250,000 and your
one-stop shopping helpline and many many
folks good folks like Chris Lodz and
others in Agra markets who are admitted
while I'm hoping to see happiness when I
wanted to leave you with a Mayan is
we're hoping that hubs won't be
developing a routine of food and
beverages during development central we
are seeing that CBD pharmaceutical hub
starting to develop employment here
Hudson Valley is also doing some food
and beverage and and some other and some
CBD but it would be helpful at the farm
bureau is a farm collective click get
more organized so that we're not for
tripping over each other that you've got
ten farms or growing the same thing with
a partner farmer i mean a partner
processor is a market in mind so we're
not sort of in the Wild West here the
governor has been directed all of them
private development all the regional
economic development council to
prioritize this so in central New York
Bing Lakes and southern tier where
there's a lot of money from the Upstate
revitalization initiatives they're
looking for projects and they want to be
able to provide some funding to help it
so we're lucky in this regard well thank
you thank you everybody for gone along
analysis of a farmer's available to
people who want to process but we always
have given to you so we have not done
that at this point in time and so we're
working through some some foil issues on
that and just trying to understand
exactly what we can and can't release
and so we probably will have the answers
to those questions in the next couple of
weeks because we've been asked but I
mean if if processors are really
interested
extension puts out newsletters to all
farmers put ad newsletters that you're
looking for meet or you're looking for
five or what you're looking for
and they'll come to you well no foil
needed right now alright so if you would
a little good a performance to give you
speed it has to be sterilized at the
front a little or are you alone so as a
processor you could sterilize it but the
other thing is is that from what I've
been told by some of the authorization
holders is one of the things that they
want is to be able to use the
unsterilized seed and some and some
products and that there are some
attributes of the seed you know before
it's roasted or before it's denatured in
some other way that are beneficial and
so what I would say as long as it's not
moving beyond the borders of the state
where we can't really have any real
impact on you know changing that policy
today
you know work with work with us to
figure out how to get it to where it
needs to go yes sir
clarify while we navigate the gray area
can you get an application to grow for
CBD only in New York State vapor so that
one okay as far as the processes go our
extractions part of that dialogue
absolutely so what what's going to
happen on CBD a little bit more detail
on that I guess I lost over it a little
bit so a little bit more detail on that
is the Department of Health has asked us
to put several CBD related questions on
the application so that we can flag
projects that need to have somebody with
a health nutritional or medical
background help us to review and so
those are probably going to go into a
separate pile and we will have a group
of folks from our department as well as
from Department of Health who will be
looking at those and trying to navigate
those through the system and understand
exactly what it is that you're wanting
to do
and what we're contemplating and again
this is early on and it's an important
detail that you asked about we'll
probably we have a what's called a
research partner agreement so the way
the process works right now is you
submit an application we act upon it we
say we like your project and then the
next step is we send you our research
partner agreement which is basically
outlining what your responsibilities as
our research partner at this with the
State Department of Agriculture what
your responsibilities are what our
responsibilities are and so in that
agreement on the CVD end of things there
probably will be some specific clauses
that are inserted in there there again
trying to build you a safe harbor within
what we currently know about CBD and
it's every state is struggling with the
CBD bank because there's a lack of
clarity we'd say one more thing that set
out in Oregon we struggle with in Oregon
had a thousand acres planted last year
and then three thousand acres planted
this year much of its receiving date
there is not enough infrastructure to do
anything with this material there's so
limit limited on international
facilities food grade approved
facilities it all is flour and it's
going out of state right get extracted
because it has to be yeah and there's
definitely some challenges with that and
we were in a processing plant in
Kentucky you know one part of it was
perfect for a food grade work the other
part was was fiber and you know
structural materials and you know I
think they said that's one of the
biggest plants in the country and it
wasn't very big so you know that's as I
said you know the bookends the seed and
the processing the processing piece is
vitally important going forward egg them
some people have mentioned grow our
coops and collectives and things like
that and Cornell does have a resource in
Bobby Severson and the Dyson school
it provides guidance in terms of co-op
formation so there is that resource if
you would like to pursue it thank you
that's very hopeful so Chris maybe we
should wrap up and let folks talk to
everyone individually and walk around
the plots of it sounds great thank you
I'm going to get some water
[Applause]
you